hello my name is August and I claim to
be a designer and up until about July
last summer I worked down the street but
now I work for a start-up called Varro
and Varro is on the homestretch of
becoming the first mobile only national
bank in the United States but really
it's also part of helping serve people
who are excluded or underserved by
traditional banking and for the first
time in my career it's a job that my mom
actually understands oh I could do until
I started talking about the clean
dataset and how we start applying
machine learning to it and then she gets
lost all over again
but part of Varro is also addressing of
a kind of title of this talk which is
designing a new American dream and I'll
get to that in a bit but prior to Google
I was at Microsoft where my last role
there was Head of Design at Xbox and I
also led design at Pinterest and then I
found my way down the street and what's
funny about those kind of sequences when
I tell people I work at Xbox I'd often
hear oh my husband or boyfriend or son
would want to meet you and when I told
people I work at Pinterest I'd hear my
wife or my girlfriend or daughter and
when I was at Google know who wanted to
meet me so I've been a designer for
close to thirty years and the biggest
thing I've learned in all that time is I
know nothing so what I'm sharing with
you today is just what I believe today
and it's subject to change but I'm going
to begin with provocation and a
confession and the provocation is this
whenever I see a bendable straw I see a
love story and the confession is I'm not
a very well rounded person I just obsess
about design I look at everything
through the lens of design and and its
own way it's kind of like a curse to
so in the more than a decade that I
lived in the state of Washington I would
get this kind of special road rage
looking at the car in front of me and
just being annoyed that the letter
spacing between the W and the a was too
much and if you've ever seen the movie
Helvetica in it there's a very
opinionated italian-american designer
named Massimo Vignelli who literally
brought Helvetica when it was metal type
in wooden cases to the United States and
as part of my design geekery had the
honor to study with him and learn as
much about a visual design from this
legend and here he is showing me the
five colors that I would need for the
rest of my design career so as I
mentioned my design career has spanned a
few decades and the first part of it is
kind of like it happened thank you
it happened in like three cities the
first of which is Boston and this was in
the 90s during the dot-com bubble and
like the pictures of my work are so tiny
because this is really a jingly we got
excited when CRT monitors went from 640
by 480 resolution to 800 by 600 so all
my work from back then was like postage
stamps and then as 2000 was kind of
rearing its head the dot-com bubble
burst and I packed up and moved to
Amsterdam and the Netherlands where I
worked for Philips design and I kind of
picked up three things during my
experience there the first is I started
learning about the interaction between
hardware and software electronics and
industrial design here's an example of
there is a group that did socio-cultural
trend analysis like really swanky hotels
in restaurants that later informed the
colors materials and finishes of things
like shavers the second thing is I've
exposed to the long-term vision of the
company which asserted the
the home of the future which is depicted
at the bottom of this illustration will
resemble much more the home of the far
past of than the home of the present
where our domestic environments are kind
of littered with boxes of Technology and
this was kind of a first floor a into
the notion of ambient intelligence or
ambient computing and one of my projects
back then was this is a model of a
potential tablet with a multi-touch
interface with a kind of fabric binding
keep in mind this was all smoke and
mirrors this was in 2001 so if we look
at it today I could kind of imagine
going into Best Buy and seeing something
like this and the third thing that I
picked up in the Netherlands is being
able to parse really long compound words
so this word translates roughly into the
police station for foreigners and as a
foreign national living in the
Netherlands I had to register with this
organization on a street with this name
and let me help you parse this out so
that last bit at the end is line which
is like Lane so that's the name of the
street but when you lop that off I
realize it was a street named after
someone named yan housing huh and like a
good new arrival in a foreign country I
decided to look up who that was the he
would deserve a street named after him
and it turns out that housing was
considered one of the greatest twentieth
century historians in the Netherlands
and this kind of seminal work is a piece
called homo Luden's which means the
being that plays and in it housing uh
suggests that play is a kind of natural
element something that predates even
human culture that it's something that
exists in nature and because of
industrialization the notion of play has
been trivialized to the realm of leisure
and relaxation when in fact it could be
at the heart of community and social
interaction
and that kind of planted a seed that
kind of germinated over the next 20
years and so I spent three years in the
Netherlands and this is how I
characterized those three years the
first I thought this is a designer's
paradise look at the Helvetica
everywhere and there's like the Dutch
tradition of product design particularly
in domestic environments and then the
government systems of identity systems
and graphic systems are so well designed
and my second year there I just kind of
fell into the groove like with my Dutch
colleagues and bike to work go to work
we were told not to work after 5:00
because I guess that's a European thing
I don't have beers and then I was like
those rinse and repeat the third year I
wanted to do was go home there's nothing
like living overseas to make you get in
touch with your own national identity
and one example of this is when as I
felt one of the things that drew me is
oh you get ten weeks of vacation a year
I thought well this was great but what I
learned is I'm really American in the
sense that I'm working cest
so come November I get a call from my HR
saying hey you have six weeks of
vacation left you should not show up to
work until January and I was like well I
can't get anything done so during my
third year I just really wanted to come
back to the United States and I ended up
coming to Seattle because I got an offer
from Microsoft and full disclosure at
that time Microsoft was a company and
organization but I held with a little
bit of disdain but I thought well I can
come back to the United States and I'll
work there for a year or two and then
move on somewhere else that plan turned
into 14 years in Redmond and here's why
not only did I learn to design at this
incredible scale of Microsoft offered
but I learned that within the company
there were so many pockets that would
fulfill all my curiosities and interest
for example during my time there I
worked in this one group called the
windows hardware innovation group and
this was a hardware group but they
weren't responsible for mice and
keyboards but rather on solid UI the
helped highlight some of the features of
Windows for example my boss in the grave
steve connect a-- he helped popularize
the scroll wheel on the mouse and my
colleague who sat next to me Carl he was
part of the group that helped pick the
colors of the connectors on the back pcs
one of the projects that I had there was
there was a version of Windows coming
out soon and we realized no one was
really using that Windows key on the
keyboard as much as they should so in
addition to create a new functionality
around it I was part of the group that
helped design the spec for this new
Windows key and I thought wow it's just
one key of us will take maybe three days
five days tops
it doubles eight month project and the
reason why is we had to take into
consideration every possible form factor
of every possible PC that would have
this key in every market the windows
being sold which is basically everywhere
so that included health and safety
standards sustainability standards my
favorite one was in Germany there was
actually a safety standard for the
amount of light that can bounce off of
your keyboard into your eyes so we had
to tweak of the finishes on the spec to
meet that standard and so this is the
key so if you see for like the little
domed one I was part of that team
in fact when I'd fly back to Seattle one
time the customs official was asking
questions said so you're a designer what
do you design and I said well do you see
that key on your keyboard right there
that was mine and I'd like awesome home
ah I want to do that today
so come 2013 I landed what I would have
characterized then is my dream job which
was helping Lee design for the then
forthcoming Xbox one and basically I was
leading design for everything but the
games is the whole platform and during
that time I was obsessed with getting a
good night's sleep I'd read in some
article that suggested oh the status
symbol of today is having a really great
night's sleep so in this kind of
obsessive designer approach I just kind
of threw myself whole hog into it and I
got into thread counts and different
strands of cotton and the right number
of layers for your sheet and I ended up
buying this really overstuffed duvet
with just the right down percentage and
it was like this big fluffy thing and it
was the beginning of the summer right
when we completed we hit design complete
for the Xbox one and that weekend I
thought I was like falling back into my
bad because this duvet looked really
huge and I turned out that instead of
landing in my bed I fell on the floor
and hit my back against the rail and
what this did is I started feeling a bit
sick and I ended up going to the
emergency room a few times and because
of hospital error I ended up in this
wheelchair and that could be a whole
other story and I don't mean this to be
a downer so I'll just kind of gloss over
that part but for the next six months I
was basically recovering and learning my
new normal and the one thing that would
help me feel like I was whole again was
getting back to work and so after six
months I ended up getting back to work
on the eve of the launch of the Xbox
console that we had helped design so I
got to miss all the squabbling between
marketing and engineering
designed and so forth and I could just
come back and reap the rewards but in
typical corporate American fashion while
I was gone the entire company had a
reorganization and so there are these
like tectonic shifts of all the
different business units and so when I
returned I found that design had been
centralized and I had a new boss and all
the respective heads of design and
things like Windows Xbox msn and so
forth we all reported to the same person
and our leader asked us to come up with
a design agenda and actually in actual
which are like traits or themes that
kind of connected all of these Microsoft
products and the thing that I've been
top of mind for me in in contributing to
this design agenda obviously it was like
accessibility and this is something that
I've been interested in prior to my
accident but since you know I was kind
of biased at that point I was like well
we should really double down on
accessibility and in kind of exploring
this theme as part of the design agenda
we explored ideas of like Universal
Design and inclusive design and and
there was something there there was a
there there and just for the purposes of
this discussion I want to point out that
oftentimes I hear these terms use
interchangeably but accessibility is not
the same thing as the two things at the
bottom of the screen accessibility is an
outcome and things like Universal Design
and inclusive design are approaches two
of many to achieve that desired outcome
where Universal Design on the one hand
kind of focuses on the end result where
the end result of a solution kind of is
accessible to as many people as possible
which is kind of like a
one-size-fits-all solution and contrary
to that or like parallel to that is
inclusive design was actually focused as
much more on the Genesis or the
beginning
of the design process and to kind of
help explain why inclusive design is a
little bit different like the sense of
the universal design is one size fits
all
I'd say inclusive design is like one
size what's
fits one but assumes it benefits
everyone else and inclusive design has
been around for a long long time but I
think it had its kind of popularity
about 15 20 years ago when the General
Assembly of the United Nations drafted
the convention of rights for people with
disabilities in 2006 and in that draft
in that convention they redefined
disability from what was called the
medical model to the societal model in
other words the medical model suggests
that disability is a direct effect of
some sort of physical or cognitive
difference while the societal model on
the other hand suggests that it's not
that rather it is a mismatch it is a
misalignment between any person's given
spectrum of abilities and the
environments and artifacts with which
she or he interacts and one of my
colleagues at Microsoft who
coincidentally both ended up in Google
her name is Kat Holmes and she is both
an inspiration and a pioneer in this
field he's written a book of the same
name mismatch that talks about inclusive
design but the kind of damning
conclusion about this redefinition is
that disability is in fact designed and
so in thinking about how to solve that
inclusive design starts off again with
solving not for a kind of average user
or a spectrum of abilities but it begins
with one person and N equals one and it
assumes that that solution will benefit
others and if we kind of like scratch
beneath the surface of that we find that
a kind of inclusive design approach
actually leads to
a long history of innovations take for
example the remote control so the
original design intent of the remote
control was to help people with mobility
differences he couldn't get up and cross
the living-room to change the channel or
the volume on their TV but you jump a
few decades ahead all of us expect the
remote control is a kind of de-facto
feature any TV that we buy and if we if
we go on and think about this kind of
inclusive design N equals one solution
vint cerf help whose hard-of-hearing
wrote some of the early email protocols
so he could communicate with his deaf
wife much more seamlessly and then the
keyboard was invented by an Italian
aristocrat whose lover a blind Contessa
wanted to be able to write letters
without assistance so that they could
communicate more easily and I can only
imagine what the content of those
letters are I think of about closed
captioning when you're in a noisy bar or
at the airport we all take advantage of
closed captioning the telephone was
originally intended as a device to
assist the deaf there's the electric
toothbrush cruise control this was
developed by an engineer who had a low
vision that wanted to drive again and
then think of the last time you listen
to an audio book which brings us to the
bendable straw so the bendable straw was
invented in San Francisco in the 1930s
and it's kind of ironic that San
Francisco's one of the first city to ban
these things but Friedman was the sky
that he took his daughter a little
five-year-old Judith to a soda fountain
and she had a milkshake and she was kind
of fussing with it because a little
five-year-old
the milkshake glass was really tall and
the straw went even further so she had
trouble drinking
her milkshake and so when Joseph
Friedman got home he took a straw put a
screw inside of it and with dental floss
kind of wrapped it around and created
the first bendable straw and so today we
all benefit from bendable straws
especially if you've ever been forced to
drinking while in bed or lying down but
the thing about all these innovations
the kind of common thread with inclusive
design is that they're all kind of love
stories they're all expressions love and
affection from one person to another and
that these inventions came about because
of that and that is why when I see a
bendable straw I see a love story
so to kind of give a really high-level
approach to inclusive design there's
basically three steps first seek out
exclusion whether it's you yourself that
is experienced exclusion or someone else
and then solve for the personal solve at
that scale about that one-on-one scale
assuming that this solution might affect
or benefit someone else and then slowly
scale it to the universal one of my
inspirations is the legendary Charles
Eames he said designed for someone you
love that someone might be you and so
this whole notion of love stories kind
of colored my lens of design of the
world and at that time there seemed to
be a bit of attraction that there's
attention being drawn and like the
agenda of design at Microsoft is now
fully embracing inclusive design and at
that time and here's my humblebrag Xbox
one our second technical Emmy Award and
so I thought well this might be a good
time to explore new things and think of
how to apply inclusive design elsewhere
so during that time I got a call from
the co-founder of Pinterest and we just
kind of hit it off right away and that
initial call I said well Evan
this is a visual platform how about what
are we gonna do for people who have low
vision or I can't see and so kind of
like a Johnny or Jenny Appleseed I
packed up moved to the Bay Area and
joined this organization but in kind of
my going through this journey and
thinking about inclusive design and how
to build off or expand this approach it
raised this question if disability is
designed then couldn't the opposite be
true that couldn't well-being be in fact
design and the answer is yes in that
little seed that was planted in the
Netherlands some years ago kind of
helped me confirm that and the answer
lies in videogames so if you think about
videogames what is the primary design
intent of pretty much any video game it
is to make you feel something it is to
generate a set of emotions and there's a
paper by Robin Hunicke and others that
describes a model to kind of fine-tune
emotional reactions the the video games
produce and it's called the mechanics
dynamics and aesthetics model or the MDA
model and here's kind of like my
nutshell description of it the mechanics
of a video game are the one-to-one
relationship between a user's input and
systems output so take this example here
if I press the button the avatar and the
screen jumps up and down if I press the
directional pad the avatar on the screen
or in side-to-side each of these is a
mechanic then if I'm curious enough I
can combine the two and do a running
jump which creates a third mechanic so
you're with me so far
if we think outside of the realm of
video games the system applies as well
so if you think about chess there are 91
mechanics to the game of chess the
definition of the pieces how they move
how a game is won or
on the board 391 mechanics to chest and
soccer for example has 17 mechanics that
comprise the game of soccer all right so
when you take the sum of this real set
of mechanics and you bring people into
it what you get is a dynamic you get the
kind of runtime behavior of the system
so you like here's level 1 of Super
Mario Brothers but bring along the
example of chess even though the
mechanics of chest have been the same
for centuries because we bring in people
with their own experiences their own
biases their own emotional states no to
chess games are ever the same and the
same is true with soccer as well and
when you think about the sum total of
the dynamics of the system what it
produces is the emotional response the
aesthetic it is it is the the thing that
produces that kind of desired emotional
response and what's interesting about
this is even though video games are
created out of fiction the emotions that
the player feels are 100% genuine the
the feelings of victory and frustration
grief or joy they are all true and if
you think about that then there's a
whole spectrum of emotions that come
along with chess and like when I think
about soccer and the most recent World
Cup if you tie in things like national
identity you can create aesthetic
responses on an international scale and
just as a side note part of my own
graduate work was looking at applying
this MDA model mechanics dogmatic model
to industrial design to examples that
I'm gonna share is like if you go into a
kitchen that has these slow close
drawers you know where you you don't
just slam a drawer shut you just kind of
push it and then kind of eases in that's
the mechanic of the kitchen drawer
it communicates this is a great kitchen
the same is true with like a luxury cars
there's so much attention to the
mechanic of how that door feels when you
shut the door and what it creates is
this kind of emotional response that
this was a well-made car all from that
one mechanic of how a door shuts this is
very satisfying complete feeling so this
model creates a directional stack where
from a player users point of view they
are first and foremost aware of the
aesthetics of a system how the thing
makes them feel and then slowly over
time they become more aware of the
dynamics and ultimately the mechanics of
the system but from a designer's point
of view it's the reverse we were in the
weeds of the mechanics of the system and
we hope that there's this kind of
aesthetic desired aesthetic response and
the way to kind of bridge that gap is
through a lot of methods of user
research but the thing that I hope you
take away from this piece is that the
only thing that can be directly designed
are the mechanics of the system so I'm
bill Buxton often gave this piece of
advice of the the fidelity of a
presentation should match the fidelity
of its thinking and this was when he was
talking about the benefits of sketching
and so forth well there's another
designer out there the sir it's a kind
of corollary to all this which is little
the resolution of the solution should
match the resolution of its problems
face and so I was inspired by a film by
Charles and Ray Eames called the powers
of 10 and here are some stills from it
but basically the powers of 10 suggests
that you could look at the same
phenomenon and in this case if you look
at the second row all the way on the
right there's a man at a picnic with
someone else and he's taking a nap on
the picnic blanket but going through the
powers of 10 every second the
magnification changes from zooming all
the way out to the Galactic scale down
to in some versions of the film the
subatomic scale and kind of applying
that in building off of the MDA or
mechanics dynamics in aesthetics model
that we could zoom down even further to
a kind of what are the components that
comprise the mechanics of the system and
the some of those mechanics then built
the dynamics and the some of the
dynamics then build the aesthetics so
what does the sum of all the aesthetics
build well I would assert the it creates
a state of being the I mean if you want
the fancy $100 word where this the
ontological layer of the system so by
thinking about it this way this is kind
of like the big idea that by affecting
the mechanic layer of any system you can
find a path to the kind of state of
being of the users or players of that
system are experiencing so in this in
this sense it's perfectly possible to
design human well-being by understanding
the different mechanics of the systems
they interact in our everyday lives
which brings us to the American dream
now I mentioned that when I loved
overseas there's nothing like living in
a different culture to make you feel
intimately aware of your own national
identity and what's interesting about
the whole myth of the American Dream is
it's kind of nasty actually the here's a
little shorthand or the first part of it
and this this is like the kind of
feel-good part of the mythologies you
can be anything you could do anything as
part of the American Dream but then it
starts turning into this kind of
double-edged sword where it's this kind
of just world philosophy in other words
the you are successful because of all
your hard work
separate of any of the systems or
context in which you've achieved this
kind of success and the kind of other
side of that is that if by any reason
you feel like you're a failure or you
have succeeded well that's all on you
and it gets even worse there was a
recent interview with the French
novelist we shall be back who was was
criticizing the American dream we're
here especially in the u.s. we kind of
suggests the the American Dream is that
financial success is somehow equivalent
to a sense of morality
I'm not gonna go further into that one
but we all know that all of these three
are obviously not true but the kind of
symbol of the American Dream that kind
of white picket fence the house the car
the 2.5 kids is is equally and obviously
no longer relevant and the research team
where I work suggested this that the
current notion of the American Dream is
based on three things first is freedom
the freedom to pursue your applications
in your work in the way that you think
is best for you and the second is this
notion of security where you don't have
to worry about financial stress the the
notion of personal finance is that it
creates this unnecessary anxiety and
these level of stress because of some of
the components of the American Dream and
then finally there's this notion which
personally I think is kind of cliche so
rather than saying happiness it's a
third theme of the new American Dream is
really kind of deriving a sense of
satisfaction so even if you're toiling
some labor the isn't you're like number
one passion it's perfectly possible to
find a sense of satisfaction from that
and these are the kind of three themes
of the new American Dream but I think
the most important thing
that is a shift from a what or an
objective definition of the stream to
the how the the dream is really about
how we live our lives so in furthering
this whole notion about getting the
right a resolution for a solution to
this I was reminded of the San Francisco
premiere of this documentary around
dieter Ron's he is considered like the
legend the foremost figure of industrial
design in the 20th century and after the
screening this was me in the back row
where all the wheelchair spaces were in
the Castro theatre I took this picture
but after the screening
the director Gary host wit and Tim Brown
got up to make a few remarks about
dieter Ron's and the whole notion of his
famous ten commandments of what good
design is and you'd have to look it up
about what all ten ten of this
commandments are but what they suggested
was this is he was the first and the
last true product designer in the
twentieth century
mental model of a product designers and
they kind of cast a gauntlet saying that
the those those ideas of good design
need to be evolved particularly now as
we enter with the World Economic Forum
calls the fourth Industrial Age where
the spheres of physical the digital and
the biological or all starting to blur
with one another so being the kind of
reckless designer that I am I have the
temerity to kind of suggest an amendment
to de France's ten commandments of what
good design is and so here they are good
design in the 21st century is first and
foremost inclusive and I touched a bit
about that earlier the second is the the
good design in the 21st century
is playful and I'm not talking about
video games
I think playful in the sense that
there's so many different definitions of
playful I think the biggest sense of
this word is that the idea of fun is
literally an environment in which it's
possible to have exploratory learning
and as anyone knows about exploratory
learning failure is part of exploratory
learning so it's incumbent upon us to
create systems that don't make the users
feel stupid or diminished or denigrated
by failing because that is a natural way
of being playful
the third is good design indoors and in
us in the same way that inclusive design
is both a critique and a complement to
accessibility approaches I would argue
that enduring design is both a critique
and a compliment to ecological
sustainability we're more often we think
about the post use fate of products and
services in terms of ecological
sustainability but what this approach
suggests is again look at the genesis of
it and think about how to maximize the
use of a product or a system and the
example that I show here is Legos where
I could take a Lego brick from My Father
set a Lego brick from my set a Lego
brick for my child set even though that
set could have Bluetooth radios and
motors in it and they all work together
the the these are designs that endure
and what kind of crocks of enduring
design is that they're almost like
linguistic organisms that there's a
systematicity to it that allows it to
endure across generations in terms of
relevance value
use um the fourth and they're only going
to be five is the good design preserves
dignity and we draw from the practice of
architecture here where there are
certain ways of portraying space that
actually affect one social behavior in
that space and keep in mind software is
in fact a mediated space as well and so
if you think of this kind of spectrum
where if the the far ends of the
spectrum there's a very public place
like the highway or the freeway so take
the 101 if someone cuts you off there's
no constraint to just letting loose
verbally gesturally how you feel about
that person who just cut you off even if
in that car it's a parent rushing their
child to the hospital or the emergency
room it doesn't matter what a jackass at
the opposite end of that spectrum if you
think about one's bedroom again it's
like a deeply private space and again it
removes these kind of constraints of we
don't typically find in public semi
public or semi private spaces but where
it gets really interesting is this kind
of middle where it's possible to create
social dynamics of both semi-private
spaces like a living room which is the
part of your domestic environment where
you receive the public or semi-public
spaces like restaurants where there's
that advice that if you're gonna break
up with someone do it in restaurant or a
cafe because it'll help preserve both
parties dignity is although I don't know
I've seen some messy breakups and cat
things but you get the idea and then
finally good design in the 21st century
is serene and this builds off of the
work of amber cased and the notion of
calm you acts but the reason why I chose
Serena's I have this kind of habit of
geeking out on Wikipedia
and I know the certain aristocrats in
Europe should be addressed as his or her
serene serene Highness I was like what's
up with the serene well I think there's
part of like a nobility like there's a
nobility to the behavior of the one
makes one's presence now and one and
other times it steps back and if we
think about our relationship with
technology today we're constantly
bombarded by alerts and buzzers and
notifications when in fact I would argue
the systems and artifacts that we create
should be serene in the sense that it
makes themselves present when it's
appropriate and in the kind of nobility
sense it deserves its place in the
context we exist so I'm thinking about
these five things I would argue not only
can we realize a kind of human
well-being but also a humane well-being
so I'm gonna leave you with these
provocations the first is this seek out
exclusion and use it as a starting point
for the work that you do and you will be
surprised probably in a good way where
you mind it up the second is the think
universally in like a really brash
audacious way and then tone it down
solve at the personal level and just get
that one-to-one solution as good as
possible for the person or people that
you're serving and finally realise this
that there is a path between the
mechanics of the systems the artifacts
the spaces environments that you design
and create and the players occupants and
users of those so in order to really
understand that engage directly with
people so now--so invite in doing so not
only
we realized possibly in the American
dream but also embrace the nobility of
our collective professions as makers
doers and creators to foster a kind of
global sense of humane will be thank you
for listening so I was told to leave
time at the end for questions are there
any questions is everyone in - hey how
you doing this in Barra
especially the bar conclusion so there
are a couple things to know about Vario
well let me step back and talk about
what's going on in the United States you
might have read in in recent articles
about those notion of banking deserts in
other words traditional banks are
pulling out of rural areas out of the
Rust Belt out of lesser serve zip codes
and major metropolitan areas this is
just one symptom of something far
greater which is the not only our
banking deserts happening but these same
areas are suffering from from what yeah
the education pharmacies healthcare
libraries the where the banks are
disappearing
everything else is disappearing - that
these are points of interaction in our
communities that now they're just the
vast majority of Americans are starting
to live in these kind of
deserts of not just banking of all sorts
of social services and community
interaction and so um one way to think
about it is well why don't we leverage
technology and let's kind of disembodied
way of that if you create common-sense
financial services the obviate the need
for like a physical store or a location
we're kind of heading that way and this
isn't far-fetched to think that ten
years ago the notion of watching a movie
you have to like get a video store
something or mail on your DVD now is
just all mobile only online only not
only is that true with with with film
the music and other entertainment as
well so why not why not banking too so
there's that one piece I should just
give a whole lecture about it but
basically that's the problem we're
trying to solve the traditional banks
have this kind of centrally old legacy
which comes with its attendant baggage
which is what makes those systems very
difficult to change so the kind of
promise of new banks are these
challenger bags is that we're starting
with a kind of clean slate where we can
offer services without fees or minimum
deposits or without just any sort of
exploitive policies and just get people
to DANC freely all right next question
because I feel like you know disability
and ability and their well-being and
maybe like having a bad or you could
still be completely able so I don't know
I just like to see how was your
implication when you work from design
for being ability to this again these
these are just these are frameworks
these are approaches and it's
challenging to talk about it in the
abstract but yes I totally agree with
you
I I really enjoy my life despite the
challenges like I face and I think it's
perfectly possible but I think for
people that create these systems and
design these systems it's much more
important to be aware of the
implications of both the use and misuse
and abuse of the systems that we design
for both well-being and satisfaction
it's not to suggest the it's a
one-size-fits-all solution or that we're
gonna solve everything but you know this
systemic problems require systemic
solutions so we just chipping away at
all hi what challenges does we're trying
to prepare were creative design and one
instance additional dimension that
you're you're mentioning sort of the
transition so banks libraries whatever
art and the other is sort of a human
dimension and how you differentiate it
when you said play or they no I don't
mean just in what this directions would
design
okay I think they were like five
questions oh that's cool so let me let
me try and hit what I think I heard so
the first is the virtual versus of the
actual human interaction is that was
that the question or design help what's
the confusion that I think I have
between the the the the the week we we
are down I feel we're done a path of
confusion between three German and and
physical worlds and whether designs all
right I'm gonna kind of be tricky here
and answer your question with a question
so one of my professors in grad school
was in waiting in line and at the
history of the Museum of Natural History
in New York and there was an exhibit to
see kalach Galapagos turtles and the
line stretched for blocks and so while
she was waiting in line with with her
daughter she decided to start asking
people on line let me ask you those if
at the end of this line when we look at
the Galapagos turtle if that turtle was
actually just a very sophisticated
animatronic robot representation of the
Galapagos turtle would it make a
difference that's the question or in
other words like when when I when I
posed of the video games are a fiction
yet they generate a kind of emotional
response and those emotions are
absolutely real at what point does the
means for generating those genuine
take emotions actually matter this is a
question I'm not going to claim I know
the answer but yes for me I would say we
just have to be thoughtful about the
means and the outcome because like my
critique of something like I know those
being recorded something like Facebook
it's like and I've been off Facebook for
a while the that's not really friendship
that's kind of like the blow-up doll
equivalent of friends you know so there
there's a spectrum I would argue where
the outcomes can actually be genuine but
somewhere along the way they're they're
just really or zat's and shallow and
there's everything in between so I guess
it's up to us as designers or creators
to figure out that sweet spot of when I
kind of when when a fiction creates an
actual real outcome yes I really I
resonate with the idea that we start
small and yet I think that also leads to
a an outcome that we as designers we've
been critiqued for a lot which is why is
it for example that people could get
philanthropy anywhere around the world
but they always keep it sort of to their
own neighbors right that we are sort of
we're blind to the broader problems
because we're only sort of looking at at
at arm's length and this comes out in
lots of different ways like Oh Silicon
Valley is just designing for Silicon
Valley and these kinds of things so I'm
wondering how is that something you
worry about when you when you sort of
push this philosophy of find someone who
you love or you would care about when
inevitably it means that because we're
homophilic we're gonna just basically be
finding people who are already sort of
in our social circles or do you or there
are ways you think that we should try to
get beyond that in another perspectives
oh the latter for sure
the we just seek it out I wanna like I
want to build the design practice of
what you're suggesting yes but you know
what we often teach right now is like go
you'll build empathy with this group but
that often can come across really weird
where there are power dynamics you know
work George Annan is the designers like
hey we're from Stanford and you know
we're going to design for you and that's
that's problematic in its own right so
how do we get our heads around this in a
way that feels like empathic and coming
from a place of love and yet doesn't
like is also feels like it's not messing
with those like power relationships in a
bad way oh let me just address a
fraction of that which is I think
they're kind of like three levels of
abstraction of how to bring about that
kind of empathy where like the furthest
one is this notion of just being
informed like we do a literature review
and read as much as we can about a
problem space that's like the furthest
out and as we get even closer it's just
kind of like direct observation like how
are people using this thing or how do
they live we get into ethnography
studies and so forth but the real way to
kind of get it what you're talking about
is to directly engage and kind of create
a co-creative co.design process where
the people who are excluded or for whom
you are designing are actually part of
the design process because I think that
is like the the most erect and least
telephone gaming like and and I and
there's the kind of Voodoo design
psychology as well which is I think
maybe there's just this is where I'm
talking way out of my sphere but there's
something that I would argue that people
who are drawn to does
are already have a kind of sense of
natural affinity for empathy if we think
about the early days of industrial
design before industrial design existed
some of those kind of early pioneers or
many of them were set designers in in
theater and what's interesting about
that is the set design and designing
props those designs are forced to put
themselves in the perspective or the
point of view of the people sitting the
audience looking at their work and
that's just kind of like a first step
for empathy so I've been ignoring this
side of the room I think there's time
for one more question yes the insurance
yeah and how it plays out when it comes
to like digital design when you were
talking about the Lego case but how can
we ensure ecological sustainability and
you shouldn't bug me back there are a
couple of things one of the things
that's really popular right now in the
design discourse is this notion of
design languages design systems and
we're trying to we're just scratching
the surface this notion the these these
kind of enduring examples of design or
actually one of the things they all have
in common is that they all share a
similar design language so in addition
to Lego one example would be like Chanel
so again a teenage girl could get very
excited about her grandmother's vintage
Chanel dress in the same way but that
could be passed on to the mother or soon
you know but the idea is that there's a
very strong visual language to this
thing the the has value that extends
across generations the same is true with
things like car design like their or bat
house furniture or like Vito shelving
the their modular their modular their
systemic I mean they have systematicity
so that something that was designed
previously could actually endure further
and then when we get into digital design
there's a bit of a challenge there like
the reason why I didn't want to step
into those is there I can't give you a
really concise answer but it has to do
with the notion of data dignity and then
you get into things like self sovereign
identity or let me give a hate to do
this but there was also a video game
example so when world of warcraft I
don't know your world of warcraft was
that like its heyday there was this
notion the the avatar the character that
you created in the world of warcraft
would be the first sort of entity that
could be passed down like you you you
you spent your whole gaming career
developing this character and then you
can kind of
bequeath it or hand it down to the next
generation to take over and continue so
that's just kind of like a very
superficial analogy yes there is a there
there well I don't think I'd be doing it
justice so it looks like we're at time I
want to thank you for inviting me this
was a real pleasure and thank you for
taking the time out to come listen I
understand this is crunch time this
quarter so thank you
you